[Music]
on this Monday night the suspected
attack at an Ontario mosque motivated by
hate our communities have reasons to
feel afraid the push for governments to
fight islamophobia make no mistake we
could have been at a funeral today under
scrutiny the interference investigation
Alberta's Premier now faces
the rising rate of infertility the
numbers doctors call staggering and an
inspirational loser I took action by
trying hard to lose weight a determined
dad's journey and transformation to give
his son a life-saving gift
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcha
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with urgent calls for
government action after a suspected hate
motivated attack at a mosque in Markham
Ontario a man is in custody accused of
driving his vehicle directly at a
worshiper and shouting islamophobic
slurs just after Dawn prayers Thursday
morning during the holy month of Ramadan
the reality is that this incident is
part of a broader problem of increasing
hate crimes in Canada and an
intensification of islamophobic rhetoric
Eric Sorensen reports on the
investigation and the calls for Action
to deal with Rising hate crimes
it was during early morning prayers last
Thursday that a man stormed into this
mosque made islamophobic threats and
then say Witnesses tried to run over
people with his car and there were many
worshipers celebrating Ramadan it's
mostly just Elders in the community they
hear and it's a definitely an alarming
situation are we living in the society
where we are not safe
is it
is it gonna keep going on like this no
one was injured but it could have been
much worse our communities have reasons
to feel afraid
make no mistake
we could have been at a funeral today
hours after the attack 28 year old
Sharon karuna Karan was arrested and
charged with assault uttering threats
and dangerous driving police do not
believe the attack was Terror related
but as it was at a place of worship they
are investigating it as a hate motivated
crime we are committed to thoroughly
investigating any incident of threat to
a member of our community
and we will they charge us accordingly
the man charged is from the South Asian
Community anti-islamic tensions have
Arisen in India and other parts of the
world though police here say they have
not determined a motive for this attack
Canada being the Multicultural Society
that we are Global impacts are felt
locally so that's not to say that's it
but it could be a could be a factor but
we haven't got any evidence of that at
this point in our investigation
statistics suggest that crimes motivated
by hate are increasing in this country
the targeting primarily focused on
religion race and ethnicity as well as
sexual orientation the latest data from
statistics Canada shows hate motivated
crimes increased in 2021 by 27 percent
in attacking a given religion including
anti-muslim anti-Semitism and other
religious targeting there was a 67
percent increase that same year this
Advocate is troubled by the rise in
police reported hate crimes these types
of crimes really erode and can erode the
social fabric of our nation and so
that's why we really need to work very
cooperatively to address them targeting
any community at all and of course for
Muslim Canadians members of the Muslim
Community are calling on the federal
government for more funding for security
at places of worship and on the
provincial government to speed up
legislation to combat islamophobia Eric
Sorensen Global News Markham Ontario
Alberta Premier Danielle Smith is under
investigation by the province's ethics
commissioner over allegations of
judicial interference related to a
covid-19 prosecution the Alberta NDP
released a phone call nearly two weeks
ago between Smith and a controversial
Calgary Pastor who faces criminal
charges for his involvement in last
year's Coots border blockade Smith can
be heard discussing an active criminal
case with the accused Smith defends the
call but says she welcomes the ethics
review and is fully cooperating it is
the second third party investigation of
the United conservative party government
in just over a year relating to
suspected judicial interference and it
comes just weeks before the official
announcement of the May 29 provincial
election
five days after an ice storm plunged
Millions Into Darkness tens of thousands
of households across Quebec are still
without power for some that's meant five
nights without electricity heat or warm
water and as Felicia Perillo tells us
patience is starting to wear thin
things look and also feel pretty
different in this part of Kirkland the
Montreal Suburban town was one of the
many areas hit hard by Wednesday's ice
storm and parts of it are still in the
dark frustrated a cold
uh kind of tired of going back and forth
luckily my dad is in Kirkland and he's
got power now so we've been warming up
there and showering but I would just
love to be in my house in the
neighboring city of Beaconsfield many
share that frustration they're still
waiting for a hydro Quebec to turn on
their lights after five nights in the
dark and homes are as cold as nine
degrees to sleep in your ski ski wear
not so funny yeah and to have a faux fur
coat with a Woolen hat on my couch to
read the read my magazines yeah
it's been tough yeah it's been tough at
its peak around 1.1 million customers
were without power in Quebec some of the
hardest hit were Montreal utawei parts
of Laval and the monterregi on Monday
the majority of outages remain in those
areas
it's only logical that in locations
where there are more trees close to the
network there can be more more power
outages when the there are severe
weather elements that either wind or
heavy snow or in this case freezing rain
um that can damage those trees and they
fall onto the system hydroquobec says
it's aiming to restore power to most of
its customers by the end of the day
Monday but says there may be a few
complex cases that will take longer
especially in neighborhoods like this
one where many Tree Trunks and branches
have crashed onto power lines the public
utility says those may be resolved by
Tuesday
Felicia Perillo Global News Montreal
in the U.S another mass shooting has
killed at least four people and wounded
nine others
police in Louisville Kentucky arrived as
gunshots were still being fired inside a
bank two police officers are among those
injured investigators say the lone
gunman is dead he was 25 years old and
was employed at the bank
this is awful
I have a very close friend that didn't
make it today
and I have another close friend who
didn't either and one who's at the
hospital
that I hope is is going to make it
through
it is the 15th mass shooting in the U.S
this year
one of two black Democrats expelled last
week from the Tennessee State
Legislature has now been reinstated
Justin Jones and his supporters sang as
he marched back into the state capitol
this evening Republicans banished him
and another lawmaker last week over
their role in a gun control protest on
the house floor Jennifer Johnson reports
the battle lines have been drawn as
Nashville local officials vote to
reinstate Democratic State lawmaker
Justin Jones one of two Tennessee
legislators kicked out of their jobs by
Republican colleagues for demanding
stricter gun laws the Tennessee House
Republicans attempt to crucify democracy
as instead resurrected a movement led by
young people to restore our democracy a
third lawmaker Gloria Johnson who joined
the protests on the house floor held
onto her seat by one vote raising
eyebrows with this claim it might have
to do with the color of our skin the
lawmaker is now known as the Tennessee
three joined frustrated young people who
came to the state house after a mass
shooting left three children and three
adults dead at a Nashville Christian
School
over the weekend support group of the
two lawmakers even from the vice
president as this case of heavy-handed
and possibly racially motivated politics
drew the nation's attention
he says you don't silence the people you
do not stifle the people local
Commissioners in Memphis will likely
vote to put Justin Pearson back in his
seat Wednesday but Pearson says his
district faces potential retaliation if
he gets reinstated I've already heard
that people in the state legislature in
Nashville are actually threatening our
Shelby County Commissioners to not
reappoint me or they're going to take
away funding the controversy has put an
ugly Spotlight on a state where most
people over 18 can buy any gun including
semi-automatic weapons and openly carry
them without a permit and an even uglier
Spotlight on racial tensions in
Tennessee where Republican lawmakers
have long been in control I'm tired of
the white supremacy of the Tennessee
legislature if both regained their seats
they'll serve until a special election
is held when voters who first elected
the two men will likely re-elect them
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
to the occupied West Bank now thousands
of Israelis marched to an illegal
outpost on a Hilltop demanding an end to
Palestinian attacks they also want their
government to approve new settlements in
the region as many as seventeen thousand
people took part in the nearly two
kilometer walk several government
ministers also attended including the
far-right national security minister the
March sparked Violence by Palestinians
in a nearby Village extending days of
escalating unrest Crystal gomancing
Reports
Israeli demonstrators hit the road
demanding their government to prove more
settlements in the occupied West Bank
the time has arrived for us to return to
our homes
in 2021 it was the Israeli government
that cleared The evitar Outpost
ultra-jewish Nationals agreed to leave
because the government said it would
eventually create a settlement on the
hilltop site we don't want just one
Evita we want many Aviator it's Mar Ben
gevir and other government ministers
attended the event and support creating
more settlements despite them being
illegal under international law in a
nearby Village Palestinians hurled rocks
at Israeli forces and they fired back
with tear gas
Palestinian red crescent reported dozens
were injured
earlier in the day a raid in the Jordan
Valley led to the death of a 15 year old
boy
his father says when he left his house
he saw military forces and people
throwing stones he stopped his car to
help an injured person to an ambulance
then he saw another body on the ground
it turned out to be his son Muhammad
Security Forces said they were in the
area to arrest Palestinians believed to
be involved with attacks on Israelis on
Friday in the Jordan Valley a car with
three Israeli settlers was hit with
gunfire Lucy D an Israeli British woman
who was in that vehicle and had been in
a coma since the attack died Monday her
two daughters were killed at the scene
you have been escalating attacks and
counter-attacks since Israeli forces
stormed the Alexis mosque last week
Israel continues to say it is simply
ensuring its security and that results
in more troops deployed to areas it
occupies
Crystal gemancing Global News London
it is the 25th anniversary of the
historic Belfast agreement coming up
what's changed and what hasn't for
people in Northern Ireland plus what the
Dalai Lama said to a little boy that's
ignited shock and outrage
thank you
it has been exactly 25 years since the
landmark Belfast agreement brought peace
to Northern Ireland following Decades of
violence that killed more than 3 500
people U.S President Joe Biden arrives
there tomorrow to Mark the anniversary
it was a U.S broker deal but leaders
admit it was only a step
[Music]
today a group of Irish Republicans
fought with police as they attended an
annual parade Northern Ireland's
power-sharing Parliament has been
suspended for more than a year and as
Redmond Shannon reports victims
relatives say they still feel left
behind
the Belfast Good Friday agreement was
the realization of what some thought to
be impossible an end to Northern
Ireland's brutal cycle of violence known
as the troubles it's a beginning
I mean this is the beginning of pro cess
of
now is a peaceful Belfast gets ready to
welcome U.S President Joe Biden tour
guide Steve Malone tells tourists how
much his city has changed in the past
when the violence was raging intolerance
was quite normal here and suspicion of
one group of people or the other that
has largely gone nonetheless 25 years on
it is an uneasy piece many Protestant
and Catholic Community separated by
so-called peace walls and most kids
still go to schools segregated by
religion despite current challenges the
future is great
and if you doubt that think of the
countless Labs which have been saved
this ceremony to Mark the anniversary
held at Northern Ireland's Parliament
and institution set up by the agreement
but suspended for over a year now due to
a boycott by Hardline British unionists
they say the Fallout from brexit is to
blame the UK's EU divorce creating
border headaches the peace deal never
envisaged Alan McBride is part of
another group of people that feels left
behind by the deal victims families I
just want to remember her as the
beautiful young woman that I dropped off
that morning an IRA bomb killed his wife
Sharon the agreement barely mentioned
people like him he and others object to
a British government proposal to give
amnesty to those involved in the
troubles some people won't trade some
people want Justice some people just
want acknowledgment and that's what the
British government have literally torn
apart at least there is one thing almost
everyone can agree on but there can be
no going back to the days of violence
Redmond Shannon Global News London
the Dalai Lama tibet's spiritual leader
is apologizing after video surfaced of
him asking a young boy to suck his
tongue at a public event in February the
87 year old says he regrets the incident
and the hurt he may have caused the
Nobel Peace Prize winner was taking
questions when the boy asked if he could
hug him after the hug the Dalai Lama
asked the boy to kiss him on the lips
social media post called the incident
sick and disgusting after it started
trending Sunday a statement says the
Dalai Lama often teases people in an
innocent and playful way
[Music]
infertility issues ahead the alarming
new report on the prevalence of the
disease
a sweeping new study from the World
Health Organization reveals how
widespread infertility is calling the
results staggering according to the
report about one in six people around
the world will experience infertility at
some point in their lifetime that's over
17 percent of the global adult
population the who is calling for better
access to treatment tariya Israeli looks
at the toll the disease is taking in
Canada
Cassie and Brady stay are first-time
parents but they weren't sure they would
ever have a baby we had been trying for
about three years like on our own the
Regina couple struggled with infertility
and went on a wait list for in vitro
fertilization they eventually found a
clinic in Saskatoon and traveled two and
a half hours weekly for treatment I
think that we paid upwards of like
fifteen thousand it's definitely like is
stressful emotionally and physically
financially it's a lot a stressful
situation that's often overlooked
infertility has not had much attention
globally the World Health Organization
looked at research between 1990 and 2021
and found one in six couples struggle to
get pregnant one in six is a lot of
people those numbers are roughly the
same everywhere the World Health
Organization report found little
difference in infertility rates between
high and low-income countries we know
that advanced maternal age is sort of
the most common reason we you see at
couples and patients in fertility
clinics despite the prevalence most
provinces only partially cover IVF
treatment meaning most Canadians have to
pay tens of thousands of dollars out of
pocket
and money isn't the only challenge we
have all kinds of cities and towns that
are don't have access to a fertility
specialist or a clinic we are under
Servicing
a huge population of Canadians who
actually need this care in 2020 the
birth rate in Canada hit a record low of
1.4 demographic experts say it's
increasing slightly but not quickly
enough to deal with the needs of an
aging population one of the major
reasons why our
immigration targets are so high right
now is because the federal government
speaking of Labor shortages the stays
want the government to prioritize IVF
funding we do have like a happy healthy
child and uh like we're definitely
thankful for that I know like other
people that haven't been so lucky
they're hopeful for change so other
couples don't face the same roadblocks
they did Taria israe Global News Ottawa
[Music]
determine donor next how a nunova dad is
saving his son's life by transforming
his own
[Music]
motivated by love a Nunavut man has
completed an incredible task tackling
his own health concern in order to
provide life-saving help for his teenage
son Heather urac's West on how the
father of four got to work
on the banks of Hudson's Bay way up
North you'll find the community of RVA
Nunavut A Little Less Than 3 000 people
strong
a place where every fall hundreds of
migrating polar bears Lumber through
town
you're going to constantly walk like
turn your head back and forth it's scary
when Daniel cabluzia began taking daily
5K walks last year in order to lose 75
pounds nothing not polar bears or the
blistering cold could stop him because
this was something he had to do for his
son three years ago Hunter was diagnosed
with kidney disease he needed a
transplant his sisters were a match but
so was his dad sorry I get
emotional easily I didn't want them to
go through this
operation procedure even before they
start their own
family so
I took action by
trying hard trying to lose weight
because in order to be a donation
candidate Daniel had to lose 75 pounds
the weight came off slowly but last
month on Daniel's birthday the doctors
gave the green light it was like Niagara
Falls pouring out my eyes
just Joy later on his skates Daniel has
also been able to play hockey with his
son again something they'll continue to
do after the transplant scheduled for
June Heather York's West Global News
and that is global national for this
Monday night I'm nitu Garcia tonight
here Canada is this harp seal in Bay
Roberts Newfoundland and Labrador thanks
for watching hope to see you again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
foreign